ja willkommen zu meinem heutigen
Kurzimpuls heute geht es um das Thema
der Epistemologie
hypertexteller Enzyklopädie wie der
Titel schon sagt geht es mir nicht um
Enzyklopädie im allgemeinen das ist viel
zu weit dieses Thema sondern wir gehen
zum eine Eigenschaft von Enzyklopädie
nämlich die Verweisung ineinander
aufeinander auf andere Artikel und die
Frage
ob sich daran was ändert unter den
Bedingungen der Digitalität das ist also
so das heutige Thema und ich gehe wie
sollte es anders sein auf die
ausziehklopädie von Dieter ein die jeder
kennt die hat mehr als 70.000 Artikel
das ist gigantisch dieses Unternehmen
das sagen auch die Autoren selbst in
ihrem Prospekt also ihrer Ankündigung
der Entwickler die was sie sich dafür
einen gewaltiges
Projekt vorgenommen hatten auch dieser
Prospekt lohnt sich mal zu lesen
und das ist so das Titelbild Titelblatt
diese Enzyklopädie und ich habe jetzt
ein paar Leitfragen wie wird in
Enzyklopädien Wissen organisiert und
noch genauere Rolle spielen dabei
insbesondere hypertextrelle Weisungen
das interessiert mich vor allem und
inwiefern ändert sich die
Wissensorganisation im Vergleich zu
punkten Enzyklopädien wenn es sich dabei
um digitale entwickeln handelt natürlich
denken wir jetzt alle hier an Wikipedia
aber auch diese gedruckten Entwicklungen
bedient die ausgeklopädie liegt in
mehreren Gestalten in digitaler Form vor
auch da will ich einen Blick drauf
werfen das will ich erst ein bisschen
was zu Dir sagen es gibt hier mehrere
deutsch
die vielleicht handlichste ist die in
der Mitte vom Fischer Verlag und es gibt
aber auch noch in der Anderen Bibliothek
eine sehr hochwertige Ausgabe die auch
wirklich noch Kupferstiche reproduziert
auch wie großformatiger ist dieses
Fischer Taschenbuch ist ein Taschenbuch
das kann man die Hand nehmen in eine
Hand nehmen das geht bei der rechten
nicht das ist sehr sehr gewichtig
großformatiger vielleicht auch noch hier
dieser ursprünglichen Edition
entsprechend jetzt gibt es in dieser
fischerausgabe ein paar
Auszüge man muss sich überlegen es gibt
70.000 Artikel da muss natürlich eine
sinnvolle Auswahl treffen diese Auswahl
findet man in diesen Taschenbuch und
auch die Ausgabe der Anderen Bibliothek
hat ein bisschen mehr aber lange nicht
70.000 und das ist ein Problem
wie soll man das in Übersetzungen
abbilden diesen Charakter diesen
wissenscharakter man muss nur
wendigerweise Auswahl treffen und die
meine Auswahl trifft zerstört man
zugleich dieses verweisungsnetz weil
diese außergruppe die Artikel nicht nur
alphabetische Ordnung aufweisen
wie so ein Lexikon sondern auch noch
mindestens zwei andere Dimensionen der
Wissensorganisation nämlich nach diesem
alphabetischen Ordnung gibt es noch die
Ordnung gemäß dem menschlichen Wissen
gemäß der epistomologie unserer Vermögen
komme ich noch drauf ist der Baum des
Wissens und es gibt noch die Ordnung
über textwellen Verweisungen auf
naheliegende verwandte Artikel oder auch
auf entgegengesetzte Artikel also es
gibt mehrere Organisationsprinzipien die
dieses gewaltige Wissen 70.000 Artikel
dort auch in der ausseeglocke die
strukturiert ist bringen jetzt hier so
ein paar Zitate ich will auch nicht
alles Vorlesen aus der Enzyklopädie also
aus der Selbstbeschreibung der
Enzyklopädie es geht darum die Ordnung
und Verkettung des menschlichen Wissens
so weit wie möglich darzulegen und ein
theoretisch begründetes Lexikons
entwickeln also resonie steht hier
theoretisch begründet ist die
Übersetzung von resonie
das heißt es muss ein Prinzip hinter der
Anordnung der Artikel stehen
das drüber über diese bloße
alphabetische Ordnung hinausgeht das
heißt auf den ersten Blick sieht man es
ist nur eine alphabetische Ordnung und
es bedarf einige andere Blicke oder ja
Perspektiven um noch diese anderen
wissensorganisationsformen
es geht den Autoren den Herausgebern
genau gesagt darum die unendlich
verschiedenartigen Zweige der
menschlichen Wissenschaft in ein
einheitliches System zu bringen also der
Anspruch der Ausweg ist
systematisch die Organisation soll sich
als ein System erzeugen mehr noch es
geht um die generologie also die
Entstehungsgeschichte und die Bewegung
des Wissens und die Verbindung die
Gründe die Eigentümlichkeit also die
Frage warum woher die auch noch eine
Rolle spielen sollen also nicht nur
System sondern auch genialogie hat das
natürlich einiges was sich die diese
Globalisten hier vorgenommen haben und
bezüglich der genialogie verweisen sie
auf die Vermögen des Wissens das
interessantes Ordnungsprinzip die sagen
nämlich das Gedächtnis die Vernunft dem
eigentlichen Sinn und die
Einbildungskraft sind die drei
unterschiedlichen Formen mit denen
unser Geist auf Gegenstände seiner
Gedanken einwirken danach ordnen Sie
dieses System es gibt einmal die
Geschichte
die bezieht sich auf das Vermögen des
Gedächtnis der Erinnerung die
Philosophie die bezieht sich auf die
Vernunft weil die Bereiche der
Philosophie und den Bereich der
Wissensbereich der schönen Künste
entspringt der Einbildungskraft ja das
ist natürlich auch interessant das
Wissen zurückzuführen genialogisch auf
diese Vermögen den wir das wissen
überhaupt verdanken das interessantes
Ordnungsprinzip jetzt gibt's hier diesen
Baum des Wissens na der Baum des Wissens
ist ein organisches System kann man
sagen
was zugleich auch noch genial logisch
ist das ist der Unterschied zu einem
bloßen System wo alles sein rechten
begründeten Ort hat der Baum bringt noch
die genialogie hinein nämlich die Stämme
die Zweige des weniger und mehr
entfernte von dem
ursprüngliche Struktur des Systems wenn
sie mich einen kleinen Ausschnitt den
rot markierten und zoomt rein und hier
sieht man jetzt schön also Laminat das
ist dann die Geschichte der
Erinnerungsvermögen
prismatik gibt es dann hier und so
weiter das kann man sich jetzt links
natürlich noch entsprechend weiter
verästelt vorstellen dann gibt es den
Verstand longt und da kommt dann die
Philosophie im
weiter oben und dann die Imagination
also die Fiktion die Poesie die die
Künste die kommen dann aus diesem
rechten Stamm anrichten Zweig
hervorgesprossenologische Erklärung und
jetzt gibt es aber auch noch eine andere
Darstellung nämlich das System auch hier
fokussiere ich wieder raus das ist
eigentlich wie der Baum nur diesmal noch
ein bisschen anders angeordnet ihr
tabellarisch muss immer schauen
organisiert die Artikel auch hier wieder
das Gedächtnis Erinnerungen Vernunft in
der Mitte und die
einstellt ein bildungskraft die Poesie
sieht man hier die Erzählungen die
Dramatik
und so weiter und so fort also das wird
alles weiter
ausdifferenziert über die bloße
alphabetische auslauflistung hinaus es
geht der Enzyklopädie darum und es ist
jetzt interessant weil das ist der
Artikel Enzyklopädie der sich auch in
der Enzyklopädie in der ossyklopädie
findet die ossyklopädie bleibt über sich
selbst reflexiv eine Enzyklopädie sagen
die Autoren Ziel darauf ab die auf der
Erdoberfläche verstreuten Kenntnis
zusammen das allgemeine System dieser
Kenntnisse die Menschen darzulegen mit
denen wir zusammenleben und es den nach
uns kommenden Menschen zu überliefern
jetzt kommt damit die Arbeit der
vergangenen Jahrhunderte nicht nutzlos
und für die kommenden Jahrhunderte
gewesen ist und es gibt noch weiter
damit unsere Enkel nicht nur gebildeter
seine gleichzeitig auch jugendhafte und
glücklicher werden das ist interessant
vor dem Hintergrund ist
aufklärungsgedanken muss so hatte sowas
gestritten und so hatte die aufklären
gerade kritisiert die rationale
Aufklärung nämlich dass sie keine
Aufklärung des Herzens sei das also die
Moral bei dieser Wissensorganisation auf
der Strecke bleibe diese Auffassung
teilen die enzykloplitisten nicht die
sagen wissen wenn es richtig reserviert
dokumentiert und organisiert ist das
führt auch dazu die Menschheit moralisch
zu verbessern das ist eine interessante
These
und jetzt kommen wir auf das eigentliche
Thema heute zu sprechen nämlich auf
Verweise also mich interessiert jetzt
nicht so sehr das genialogische
Wissenssystem sondern das
hypertextuelle
verweisungsorganisationsprinzip das
hinter der außergruppe die steckt und
auch in der verschiedenen auch
gegenwärtigen entwickeln die sagen
nämlich er die Autoren in der
wissenschaftlichen Abhandlung bestimmt
die Verknüpfung der Ideen oder der
Phänomene den Gang
mit dem Voranschreiten entwickelt sich
die Materie
in der Enzyklopädie ist es aber anders
nämlich da
verweisen die enzyklopädischen au
Artikel aufeinander und das sagen jetzt
die Autoren seither wichtigste Teil der
zyklopädischen also die Verweise sind
das wichtigste in der Wissensordnung der
Enzyklopädie ja und das unterscheidet
sie von einem Wörterbuch das nur
alphabetisch das ganze
aufliste zu zeichnen Liste hierbei bei
der aus der Gruppe die handelt es sich
um eine interne strukturierte
relationierte
Wissensorganisation und jetzt werden
zwei Arten von Verweisen Unterschieden
also man kann da wirklich über dieses
Thema allein über die Verweise in der
Inselgruppe die noch viel Interessantes
schreiben und
unterscheidet verschiedene verweisen
nimmt jetzt aber nur einen Blick die
Verweise verknüpfen den Zweig mit dem
Stamm und verleihen dem Ganzen jene
Einheit welche der Durchsetzung der
Wahrheit und der Überzeugung zu
förderlich ist also damit überhaupt ein
Wissen genialogisch strukturiert werden
kann im Sinne dieser Baum Metapher
stammen zweigäste Verästelung und
Blätter und so weiter müssen wir schon
das Prinzip der Verweise als
wissensorganisationsprinzip voraussetzen
also die gehen ja Logie ist nur möglich
wenn wir schon wissen im Sinne der
Verweise organisieren können natürlich
ist die genologische Organisation sehr
komplex aber sie setzt diese
verweisungstruktur voraus
und jetzt kommt vielleicht der
entscheidende Punkt der Verweise es ist
nicht nur ein
fortreichen fortpflanzen des Wissens
sondern es ist
gewissermaßen dialektisch sie sagen
nämlich doch wenn es sein muss dann
rufen die Verweise auch eine ganz
gegensätzliche Wirkung hervor sie
bringen die Begriffe in Opposition
zueinander sie lassen die Prinzipien
kontrastieren insgeheim greifen sie
lächerliche Meinungen an die man offen
zu selten nicht wagen würde erschüttern
sie stürzen sie um darin kann man jetzt
schon das revolutionäre Potenzial der
ausgeklopädie erkennen in diesen ganz
banalen verweisen die sich am Ende eines
Artikels finden also völlig unscheinbar
die lesen viele Menschen gar nicht die
wollen einfach nur den Anfang Lesen der
das Artikels und dann ist gut jetzt will
ich mal einen konkretes Beispiel geben
wie so ein Artikel gleich aussieht aber
ich will jetzt noch ein bisschen auf
diese Verweise erst noch eingehen das
Gesam gute Werk also in dieser letzteren
verweisen auch in dem problematisieren
kontrastieren legen eine große Kunst und
unermesslicher Vorteil das gesamte
werkbezüge daraus eine innere Kraft und
ein geheimen nutzen deren verborgene
Wirkung mit der Zeit notwendig spürbar
würden also erst mit der Zeit kommt der
Charakter dieser Wissensorganisation
durch auf Opposition zum Vorschein
dieser Charakter heißt sagen sie ganz am
Ende die allgemein wirkliche Form des
Denkens zu verändern man könnte das auch
das hypertextuelle denken nennen und
nicht nur das alphabetische Liste mäßige
oder auch das ähm systematische denken
das genialogen
textuelle denken und das finde ich sehr
spannendologie
und das schließe ich jetzt raus der
Leser bzw die Leserin der erste globity
muss selbst ihre eigene Ordnung des
Wissens durch die Lektüre der
ausgeklopädie kritisch entwickeln indem
sie diesen Verweisen folgt sich dann
aber ihr eigenes Ding dabei denkt und
das ist eben auch ganz im Sinne der
Aufklärung wie sie von Immanuel Kant
kennen ähm die selbstverständigen
Unmündigkeit wir lesen einfach nur
Bücher und das Wissen sozusagen einfach
rezipiert und durch diesen
verweisungscharakter kann man gerade
vermeiden dass nur wissen rezipiert wird
sondern man verbindet verknüpft Wissen
durch die Lektüre und zwar immer auf den
eigenständige kritische Art die einen
nichts sondern abnimmt der sie
entmündigt eigentlich zurecht ein an
kritisch zu denken könnte man sagen und
jetzt bringe ich das konkrete Beispiel
es gibt hier das ist aus der origin
den Artikel anthrophage anthropophage
der Menschenfresser ja
und das sind ganz bekannter Artikel man
sieht hier immer wo er je also die ist
hier die Verweise die werden meistens
nur je eingeläutet einleitet und jetzt
schauen wir uns mal den ganz zum Ende an
und
hier das Rot eingekesselte das muss uns
Stutzen machen weil hier wird verwiesen
von Menschenfresser auf Eucharistie
Kommunion und Hotel den Altar also hier
werden Verweise zu sakralen Phänomen
oder Artikeln hergestellt die man gar
nicht vermutet der Grund ist natürlich
klar die Eucharistie ist theologisch
sehr kontrovers wie man die
interpretiert und sie verweisen jetzt
von Menschenfresser darauf hin das ist
natürlich ungehört und erhört für die
damalige Zeit gewesen
und
das soll jetzt nur zeigen wie subwaysiv
solche Verweise sind ja ganz unscheinbar
am Ende aber die haben eine springkraft
ja und heutzutage gibt es
zum Beispiel von der Wiki Songs auf der
französischen Seite gibt es die gesamte
Edition die ausgekloppte die von 1751
mit dem Prospekt in den 17 beenden das
sind wirklich alle über 70.000 Artikel
sind hier digitalisiert worden und sie
sind auch über texture verlinkt worden
hier habe ich noch mal das Beispiel das
Artikels Antworten Frage auch hier wird
jetzt eben blau unterlegt über Texte
gelingt auf diese anderen Artikel in der
digitalen Edition jetzt kann man sich
fragen ob Wikipedia in dieser Tradition
der Enzyklopädie zu verstehen ist oder
was ich gegebenfalls ändert also mir
scheint dass die digitalen Entwicklungen
einer anderen Raum Zeit und wissenslogik
als gedruckte Entwicklung die ist ist
Folgen durch die Digitalisierung können
wir nämlich unmittelbar und reibungslos
über Links folgen wenn ich Fanartikel
andere profag gehabt war glaube ich im
ersten Band und dann verweist er mich
hier auf die Eucharistie dann ist es
natürlich nicht mehr im ersten Bank es
gibt 17 Bände das vielleicht der zweite
der dritte Bank mit E das heißt ich muss
dem anderen Band wirklich physisch holen
und muss aufschlagen
das kann man jetzt als eine bloße Aktie
den Teller
Unterschiedlichkeiten interpretieren
diese Reibungslosigkeit die wir durch
den digitalen hypertextuellen völlig
haben oder man kann es auch als was
essentielles überlegen also ist diese
Reibungslosigkeit der digitalen
Enzyklopädie nur was Aktivität ist oder
verwendet das tatsächlich die
Wissensorganisation selbst
ein weiterer Unterschied meine These ist
verändert die Enzyklopädie essentiell
weil es eine ganz andere Form von
Wissensraum eröffnet ein Wissensraum der
nicht mehr physisch getrennt ist sondern
der in einem viel engeren reibungslosen
virtuellen Zusammenhang ist ich glaube
das endet auch die gesamte Wissen
Ordnung
ein weiterer Unterschied ist wie
rezipieren nicht nur Artikel auf
Wikipedia wie in der anziehgruppe die
sondern wir arbeiten sie kollaborativ es
sind nicht nur die Enzyklopädie sondern
es ist jedermann von uns jede Frau jeder
Mann jedes vernünftige Wesen wir folgen
auf Wikipedia nicht nur verweisen und
denken uns dann auch unseren Teil dazu
wie bei
Menschenfresser sondern wir vernetzen
teilweise auch die Einträge selbst wir
können selbst ein Wikipedia-Artikel
bearbeiten und
von eisernen herstellen wir vernetzen
Artikel nicht nur innerhalb der
Wikipedia wie es eben bei der
auseklopädie war zu größten Teil sondern
wir verweisen auch auf äußere Quellen
und Inhalte und auch hier gilt mit einem
Klick oder zwei klicken maximal bin ich
selbst bei dem Inhalt die ausgeklappe
die konnte Verweisen auf andere Bücher
die musste ich danach schlagen aber hier
kann ich tatsächlich das andere Buch auf
der Seite den Text direkt präsent machen
und direkt auch das scheint mir dafür zu
sprechen das ist nicht nur was Aktivität
es ist was ich hier Ende das heißt die
Genese des Wissens die lässt sich sogar
noch über diese Baum Metapher hinaus
nachvollziehen durch die diskursive
diskussionsgeschichte und durch die
Diskussionen die sich begaben und immer
noch ergeben bei der Aktualisierung oder
überhaupt Erstellung von Artikeln in der
Wikipedia das heißt
mein Fazit ist digitalen Enzyklopädien
zumindest wieder Wikipedia liegt eine
ganz andere Form von Rezeption
Wissensorganisation aber auch mindestens
Partizipation zugrunde die eben immer
mehr diese Richtung des Konsumenten geht
dass man konsumiert aber auch eben
produziert mit Blick auf das